Les mondes perdus.
Pour connaître les mammifères
vivantes au temps des dinosaures,
les paléontologues ne disposèrent
pendant longtemps,
que de fragments de fossiles.
Ils pensaient que ces animaux
de la taille d'une souris,
n'avaient pu se diversifier
sur la planète,
qu'après l'extinction des dinosaures.
Mais au cours des années 2000,
la découverte en Chine de somptueux
fossiles magnifiquement préservés,
révèle que les mammifères avaient
préparé leurs armes bien avant.
L'analyse des plus infimes détails
de leur morphologie,
explique enfin comment ils ont cohabité
avec de redoutables carnivores,
et leur ont survécu.
L'aube des mammifères.
C'est au nord-est de Pékin,
dans la région volcanique du Liaoning,
que l'on trouve les fossiles
de ces étonnants mammifères.
Comme les Repenomamus.
Des animaux de la taille d'un loup,
capable de dévorer
de jeunes dinosaures à plumes.
S'ils sont aussi la proie de grands
prédateurs comme ces Yutyrannus,
ils sont bien plus imposants que tous
les mammifères anciens connus jusque là.
Ces Repenomamus, vivent
il y a 130 millions d'années,
dans une zone de fréquentes
éruptions volcaniques.
Conservez dans les fines cendres,
leurs squelettes ont traversé le temps.
Jusqu'à venir bouleverser les connaissances
qu'ont les paléontologues,
des tout premiers mammifères.
Ces fossiles de mammifères sont liés
à notre propre histoire évolutive,
dans la mesure où nous aussi
sommes des mammifères.
Les mammifères, dont le nom signifie
qui portent des mamelles,
sont les seuls animaux
à allaiter leurs petits.
Ils se caractérisent par leur poil,
une oreille dissociée de la mâchoire,
et des dents très variées.
Autant d'atouts déjà présents
au temps des dinosaures,
comme le révèlent
de récentes découvertes.
Nous observons que leurs dents
ont d'abord quelques pointes seulement,
puis qu'elles se multiplient.
Ces outils leur ont permis de survivre
à l'extinction massive des dinosaures.
Les fossiles exhumés
au début des années 2000,
datent l'apparition des mammifères
de 125 millions d'années.
Mais des analyses génétiques
suggèrent que leur origine,
pourrait être plus lointaine encore.
Depuis dix ans, la polémique rebondit
sur fond de dispute,
entre généticiens et paléontologues.
Tout commence,
il y a 250 millions d'années.
Au début du Trias.
Une période marquée
par une extrême chaleur.
Les ancêtres des mammifères
sont des reptiles mammaliens.
Comme ce Thrinaxodon.
Ce descendant des reptiles
est considérait,
comme une étape de transition
vers les mammifères.
Ses pattes ne sont pas placées
sous son corps,
mais légèrement sur le côté
comme chez les crocodiles.
Il possède déjà plusieurs types de dents,
et des poils comme les mammifères,
mais n'a pas encore d'oreille externe.
Pour se soustraire
aux températures élevées,
il creuse des galeries
le long des rivières.
C'est là qu'il s'est fossilisé.
Les nouvelles technologies rayons X
du synchrotron de Grenoble,
permettent d'analyser son terrier,
découvert en Afrique du Sud
au XIXᵉ siècle.
Grâce à cette innovation,
Vincent Fernandez peut étudier en 2011,
pour la première fois, le contenu
d'un bloc de roche sans le détruire.
Nous avons découvert
ce terrier dans un site,
qui était utilisé
pour la construction d'une route.
Et parmi tous les terriers que nous
avons découverts dans cette petite carrière,
celui-ci présentait des petits os
sur des fractures,
qui nous ont donné l'idée de le sortir
pour l'étudier, ici, au synchrotron.
Ce terrier a été enseveli
à une période charnière.
Au Trias, il y a 250 millions d'années,
70% des espèces terrestres ont disparu.
Ce bloc de roches détient
peut-être le secret,
de ceux qui ont survécu
à cette dramatique extinction.
La meilleure façon de savoir
quel animal utilisait quel terrier,
c'est de trouver cet animal
dans le terrier.
Et donc, pour pouvoir
trouver cet animal,
plutôt que de dégager
la roche manuellement,
on va utiliser
les rayons X pour pouvoir,
étudier l'animal
dans le terrier fossilisé.
Plus performants que les scanners médicaux,
le synchrotron permet de distinguer
par différence de densité,
les eaux fossilisées
de la roche elle-même.
Cette prouesse permet
de visualiser un Thrinaxodon.
ancêtre des mammifères.
Et surprise supplémentaire,
un amphibien nommé Broomistega,
allongé tout contre lui.
C'est une très grande surprise
parce que c'est extrêmement rare.
En général,
les animaux ne partagent pas
vraiment leurs terriers,
encore moins avec des animaux,
qui ont à peu près la même
taille qu'eux et encore moins,
avec des animaux qui ont
le même régime alimentaire.
Comme les Opossum surpris dans
leur terrier par les caméras thermiques,
lorsqu'ils fuient les grosses chaleurs.
Le Thrinaxodon se terrait,
au frais pour dormir
durant de longues périodes.
Profondément engourdi, il n'aurait
pas réalisé que le Broomistega,
se réfugiait dans son havre.
Cet amphibien en aurait profité
pour s'abriter du climat hostile.
D'autant que ses restes fossiles
prouvent qu'il était blessé.
On a trouvé que le Broomistega
était blessé.
Il a une série de 7 côtes cassées
qui était en phase de guérison.
On le voit parce qu'il y a des petits
calot osseux autour des fractures.
On voit le processus de guérison.
On voit qu'il était blessé depuis
plusieurs semaines, certainement.
Cette découverte révèle
que les ancêtres des mammifères,
avaient développé la capacité
d'entrer en léthargie.
L'un, blessé et l'autre endormi,
auraient été surpris ensemble,
par une violente montée des eaux.
C'est parce que la lignée
du Thrinaxodon,
était capable de vivre dans
des souterrains qu'ils creusaient,
et grâce à leur métabolisme particulier
leur permettant de survivre à la sécheresse,
que cette lignée a pu survivre
et donc permettre,
l'apparition des mammifères plusieurs
millions d'années après.
Vincent et ses collègues sud africains,
sont maintenant en quête
de nouveaux terriers à scanner,
pour espérer résoudre d'autres mystères.
On cherche soit un œuf,
soit une femelle enceinte,
qui permettra enfin de savoir,
quel mode de reproduction
avait nos lointains ancêtres.
Mais la tâche n'est pas aisée
car les fossiles de mammifères,
sont extrêmement rares
dans les gisements du Trias.
Jusqu'à la fin du XXᵉ siècle,
les premiers mammifères
ne sont connus que par leurs dents.
Tels ces spécimens millimétriques,
conservés au Muséum national
d'histoire naturelle de Paris.
Emmanuel Gheerbrant,
spécialiste des mammifères,
se souvient de ses débuts
de paléontologue.
Quand j'ai commencé ma carrière
dans les années 85-90.
La plupart des restes qu'on trouvait,
c'étaient des dents isolées,
ce qui était déjà...
Un peu, presque un rêve,
c'était de trouver non seulement
des mâchoires, mais voir des crânes.
Ces minuscules vestiges sont obtenus
au prix d'un travail de fourmi.
Pour découvrir quelques
dents de mammifères,
les paléontologues passent au tamis
plusieurs tonnes de sédiments.
Seules les dents sont bien
conservées parce que leur émail,
résiste particulièrement
au passage du temps.
C'est la partie du squelette
la plus minéralisée,
celle qui se fossilise le mieux.
L'intérêt des collections de dents
isolées de mammifères,
c'est que ce sont des restes
de petite taille.
On peut avoir des collections
de plusieurs centaines de dents,
qui vont tenir
dans une boite à chaussures,
et donc on peut avoir
la représentation d'une faune,
très diversifiée et même de toute
l'histoire d'une province géographique,
qui se résume à une collection
d'un tiroir, d'un meuble,
avec plusieurs centaines de dents.
C'est le cas de la plus
importante collection,
étudiée par l'équipe
d'Emmanuel Gheerbrant.
Débuté près de Nancy en 1976
à Saint-Nicolas-de-Port.
Elle recèle aujourd'hui près
de 1000 dents, datées du Trias supérieur.
Il y a 210 millions d'années.
C'est la plus vieille faune
de mammifères connus au monde.
Une dizaine d'espèces identifiées,
grâce à la morphologie de leurs dents.
Sur ces molaires, les trois pointes
sont en effet propres aux mammifères.
Elles sont utilisées
pour broyer la nourriture.
En complément des canines
destinées à la maintenir,
et des incisives qui la coupe.
Cette dentition complexe,
signe l'appartenance
à la classe des mammifères,
car les autres espèces animales
possèdent un seul type de dents.
La morphologie des dents,
c'est une véritable carte d'identité,
des groupes auxquels
elles appartiennent.
C'est une carte d'identité
pour identifier l'animal.
Et en plus, c'est un support
d'information fonctionnel,
c'est à dire du régime
alimentaire de ces animaux,
puisque ces dents, si elles
sont pointues par exemple,
indiquent plutôt un régime insectivore,
ou si elles ont plutôt
des reliefs aplaties,
ça indique plutôt
des régimes herbivores.
S'ils ont le mérite de révéler
le régime alimentaire des mammifères,
vivants au temps des dinosaures,
ces fossiles n'offrent aucune
indication sur leur apparence.
Mais un indice trouvé
en France en 2008,
lève le voile sur ce qui recouvrait
la peau de ces animaux disparus.
Au cœur des Charentes-Maritimes,
une carrière est abandonnée
près de la ville d'Archingeay.
Sur ce site d'extraction de sable,
deux paléontologues
de l'université de Rennes,
profitent de la mise à nu des parois
pour collecter des fossiles.
Cette couche géologique date du Crétacé.
Il y a 100 millions d'années,
une forêt de conifères et de ginkgo,
s'érigeait ici,
comme le révèle Romain Vullo
et Didier Néraudeau.
Regardez cette feuille est dans l'argile
depuis 100 millions d'années,
elle se décolle.
Et si je souffle dessus...
Je peux la tordre.
Ce qui montre bien
que c'est souple encore.
Excepté sa couleur noire,
les millions d'années ont peut
altéré ce débris végétal.
Mais c'est un autre trésor
que cherchent les paléontologues.
Un morceau d'ambre.
Car la résine coulant le long
des troncs de conifères,
emprisonne parfois
les restes des animaux.
Là, on est sur le fond de la carrière,
et on a de l'eau qui a ruisseler,
et qui a créé un petit
affleurement intéressant.
On peut voir les couches en place.
La couche apparaît étirée puisqu'on
a une alternance de sédiments différents.
On va avoir 2 grands types de dépôts.
Des dépôts sableux : sable blanc, ocre, roux.
Et après on va avoir
un autre dépôt avec une accumulation,
plutôt charbonneuse qui va former
ces petites veinules noirâtres.
Là, on voit bien l'alternance sable,
et petit lit argileux qui contiennent,
les débris de végétaux,
et les petits morceaux d'ambre
que l'on recherche spécialement.
Le sédiment prélevé est ensuite
tamisé dans l'étang tout proche.
J'ai pas mal de petits fragments.
Il y a un morceau
qui est de belle taille.
Légèrement translucide,
un peu marron, un peu rouge.
Au-delà de ce minutieux travail,
la paléontologie comporte
aussi une part de hasard.
Un indice majeur de l'apparence
des mammifères,
est ainsi dévoilé grâce à un coup de chance.
C'est en cherchant
des filaments bactériens,
qu'un collègue de Romain Vullo,
fait cette découverte rarissime.
Des poils emprisonnés dans l'ombre.
On voit l'ensemble
de la pièce d'Ambre,
et on voit au milieu,
le plus long des deux poils
qui est légèrement coudé.
Donc on voit que
c'est vraiment très fin.
Nous avons comparé ce poil fossile
de 100 millions d'années,
avec des poils de mammifères actuels,
et nous avons pu constater
que ce poil présente,
de nombreuses ressemblances
avec ce que l'on peut retrouver,
chez les espèces actuelles.
La morphologie des écailles,
va être très semblable,
mais aussi la disposition
de ses écailles.
Et leur contour présente
de fortes ressemblances,
avec les poils de mammifères actuels.
En paléontologie,
c'est une découverte exceptionnelle,
puisque les poils
de mammifère dans l'ambre,
il y en a 1 ou 2 dans le monde.
Il y a 100 millions d'années,
les mammifères possèdent déjà
les mêmes poils qu'aujourd'hui.
Équipement utile pour protéger ces animaux
à sang chaud des aléas climatiques,
et survivre aux extinctions
qui déciment les grands dinosaures.
De nouveaux indices de la morphologie
des premiers mammifères sont exhumés,
au tout début des années 2000
dans le sous sol chinois.
Dans des couches géologiques
datant du début du Crétacé,
il y a 125 millions d'années,
sont retrouvés les fossiles d'une faune,
habitant d'une péninsule,
au climat subtropical.
Dans ce monde dominé par
les immenses dinosaures,
tels ces Titanosaures,
haut de dix mètres,
vivent aussi de tout petits mammifères.
Comme Eomaia scansoria.
Littéralement, la mère primordiale
qui sait grimper.
Victime des dinosaures à plumes,
tel ce Zhenyuanlong,
Eomaia était le plus vieux
cousin des mammifères,
lors de sa découverte en 2002.
Il est trouvé dans la région du Liaoning,
au nord est de Pékin.
Cette zone anciennement volcanique,
a conservé au fil des millions d'années,
les traces de notre lointain passé.
Zhe-Xi Luo, paléontologue américain
d'origine chinoise,
longe la falaise ****.
Célèbre grâce au nombre de fossiles
qu'elle a livré.
Cette formation est un dépôt lacustre,
emprisonnant une grande variété
de fossiles de vertébrés.
Les plus fameux sont les dinosaures
à plumes, mais les plus importants,
pour comprendre l'histoire
évolutive des êtres humains,
sont ces mammifères du Crétacé.
Il y a 125 millions d'années,
les éruptions volcaniques successives
créent ces couches sédimentaires.
Les poches de cendre rouge écrasent
comme une presse d'imprimerie,
les mammifères pris dans la boue grise.
14 centimètres de long pour un
poids d'une vingtaine de grammes,
Eomaia n'échappait sans doute pas
aux dinosaures à plumes.
Et c'est peut-être lors d'une course
poursuite qu'il a trouvé la mort,
avant d'être fossilisé.
Ces fossiles de mammifères
sont très bien préservés,
parce qu'ils vivaient près
des eaux peu profondes des lacs.
Ces sédiments se sont accumulés
très lentement,
et les cendres des éruptions volcaniques,
ont aussi contribué à emprisonner
ces fossiles de mammifères.
C'est pour cela qu'ils sont
si bien préservés,
et nous offrent de magnifiques
fossiles à étudier.
C'est à Pékin, au sein
du Muséum d'histoire naturelle,
que Zhe-Xi Luo étudie les fossiles
du groupe des Eomaia scansoria.
Des mammifères placentaires,
ceux dont les petits sont nourris
dans l'utérus par un placenta,
comme les humains.
Le corps complet de l'animal
est magnifiquement préservé.
Comblant ainsi le rêve
de tout spécialiste des mammifères.
C'est vraiment extraordinaire d'avoir
ici un fossile intégral.
Ce squelette complet permet de dresser
un portrait bien plus intéressant,
des premiers mammifères.
Celui-ci vivait au Crétacé.
Sa mâchoire est gracile
et on peut voir même à l'œil nu,
que ses membres sont assez fins.
On peut deviner aussi
à ses très longs doigts,
et aux différentes structures
de ses ongles,
qu'il grimpait aux arbres.
Cela montre que les ancêtres
des placentaires,
étaient plus aptes que leurs
contemporains à la vie arboricole.
Cela nous a donné un énorme
avantage au cours de l'évolution.
Eomaia devait laisser ses petits en hauteur.
À l'abri des dinosaures qui parfois
sommeillent à même le sol.
Ces tout premiers mammifères
quittent ponctuellement,
leur nouvelle niche écologique
pour s'abreuver.
Leur extraordinaire mobilité
est révélée par ce squelette.
Et surtout par son os trapézoïde,
particulièrement allongé comme
celui des primates arboricoles.
C'est en étudiant les articulations
des chevilles,
que l'on identifie de nombreux traits,
plaçant ce fossile dans la lignée
qui donnera naissance,
aux mammifères placentaires modernes.
Quant au régime alimentaire des Eomaia,
ses dents, très bien conservé,
fournissent d'autres indices.
On voit que ce mammifère a des pointes
très acérées vers l'avant.
Et que ses dents inférieures forment
en général un triangle très pointu.
Elles sont très efficaces pour
briser les squelettes d'insectes,
ou découper la chair des vers.
Après Eomaia,
de nouveaux fossiles exhumés en Chine,
offrent aux paléontologues une nouvelle
vision des mammifères anciens.
L'institut de paléontologie
des vertébrés de Pékin,
temple des dinosaures à plumes,
conserve ses spécimens étonnants.
Dont le Repenomamus,
un squelette complet
de taille inhabituelle.
Yuanqing Wang
est le paléontologue chinois,
chargé d'étudier cette étrange
bête de 70 cm de long,
exhumé en 2004.
Beaucoup de mammifères du Mésozoïque,
ont la taille d'un rat ou d'une souris,
donc ça, c'est assez grand.
Autre particularité
de ce gros mammifère,
ses dents pointues et acérées,
sont enchâssées
dans une robuste mandibules.
Avant de trouver cet animal,
On pensait que les mammifères
du Mésozoïque,
étaient de petits insectivores vivant
dans l'ombre des dinosaures.
Vous pouvez voir que ses dents
sont pointues et tranchantes,
ce qui montre que c'est un carnivore.
Dans son estomac,
on a retrouvé des fragments d'os,
d'un bébé dinosaure nommé Psittacosaure.
Et on s'est dit : "Ok, cet animal
mangeait des dinosaures."
C'est rien moins qu'une révolution.
La preuve que certains
cousins des mammifères,
se nourrissent de jeunes dinosaures,
et ne vivent pas seulement
dans leur ombre.
Les paléontologues ignorent
comment se déroule leur chasse.
Mais par comparaison avec les loups,
ils imaginent que les Repenomamus,
traquaient leurs proies en meute.
La collection pékinoise recèle d'autres
sujets d'étonnement pour les scientifiques.
Découvert en 2006, le Volaticotherium
est doté d'une curiosité.
Un large morceau de peau relie
ses membres inférieurs et supérieurs.
À quoi pouvait-il servir ?
Observer au microscope,
Cette tache sombre révèle
la présence de poils nombreux.
Une fine membrane de peau
couverte de fourrure.
C'est un Patagium.
Tendu entre les pattes de l'animal
comme chez les écureuils volants,
elle permet à Volaticotherium
de planer depuis les arbres.
Auparavant, les plus anciens
mammifères volants connus,
étaient les chauves souris,
apparues il y a 50 millions d'années,
Avec Volaticotherium,
contemporain des dinosaures,
un immense bond dans le passé
est donc réalisé.
Ce chasseur attendait le crépuscule
pour se mettre en quête de proies.
C'est très intéressant.
Cela nous apprend que la diversité
des mammifères du Mésozoïque,
est bien plus vaste
qu'on ne le pensait.
On imaginait des animaux vivant
dans des arbres ou marchant au sol,
mais ils peuvent aussi
planer dans les airs.
Cet animal volant révèle
l'adaptation des mammifères,
à différents environnements.
Bien avant la disparition des dinosaures.
Mais malgré la découverte
de ses multiples fossiles en Chine,
une question agite toujours
la communauté scientifique,
à la fin des années 2000.
À quel point les mammifères
placentaires sont-ils anciens ?
Pour y répondre, généticiens
et paléontologues,
s'opposent à coup de publications.
Dans la ville allemande d'Oldenbourg,
des chercheurs traquent
les gènes des animaux actuels,
pour reconstituer
leur arbre généalogique.
En constatant la similarité d'un gène
entre 2 espèces de mammifères,
nous pouvons estimer
leur degré de parenté.
Olaf Bininda-Emonds est l'auteur
de ses travaux publiés en 2007,
pour lesquels les gènes de 99%
des mammifères contemporains,
ont été analysés.
Ce travail de titan requiert
8 mois de séquençage ADN,
pour pister les mutations génétiques de
60 marqueurs de l'évolution des mammifères.
Les données moléculaires vont nous
fournir une représentation plus précise.
Nous avons les données ADN d'un nombre
d'espèces supérieur aux données fossiles.
Les fossiles nous apportent
des points de repère dans l'évolution,
et l'ADN vient combler
les informations manquantes,
en nous indiquant les moments
où toutes les espèces de mammifères,
se sont séparées
de leur ancêtre commun.
Cette méthode nommée
horloge moléculaire,
montre que les mammifères placentaires
se sont séparés des marsupiaux,
il y a 160 millions d'années
au Jurassique.
Puis se sont diversifiés pendant le Crétacé
pour former les groupes actuels.
Rongeurs, carnivores et primates.
Un résultat inattendu.
Car aucun de ces fossiles n'a été
découvert dans les gisements de l'époque.
C'est très intéressant parce qu'il
existe de grands écarts,
entre les études moléculaires
et les études fossiles.
Une étude fossile réalisée
au même moment,
de l'autre côté de l'Atlantique
à Pittsburgh,
offre en effet d'autres résultats.
Elle est l'oeuvre de John Wible,
paléontologue au Muséum national
d'histoire naturelle de Carnegie.
Son point de départ,
un crâne découvert en Mongolie,
dans un gisement datant
de 75 millions d'années.
nommé Maelestes gobiensis,
il est étudié sous toutes les coutures,
car il n'appartient
à aucune espèce répertoriée.
400 traits morphologiques
sont ainsi comparés,
avec ceux de 82 autres mammifères
fossiles ou actuels.
Nous avons comparé les traits
morphologiques propres à cet animal,
à ceux d'un large éventail d'autres
formes fossiles et de mammifères actuels.
Pour tenter de comprendre qui il était
et à qui il était relié.
Notre étude conforte le point
de vue traditionnel,
disant qu'aucun animal
vivant au Crétacé,
n'était membre du groupe
placentaire lui-même.
Ils n'étaient que les ancêtres
des placentaires.
Entre étude des fossiles et analyse
génétique, qui faut-il croire ?
Les études moléculaires indiquent
toutes que les ordres du groupe couronne,
comme les rongeurs, les primates,
les carnivores ou les chauves souris,
trouvent leur origine au Crétacé,
quand les dinosaures vivaient encore.
Le problème, c'est qu'aucun
fossile ne le prouve.
Selon l'analyse
de l'horloge moléculaire,
beaucoup de ces groupes modernes devraient
être présents parmi les fossiles du Crétacé.
Nous ne les trouvons pas.
Nul doute qu'il y avait des mammifères
placentaires au Crétacé.
L'objet du débat consiste à savoir de quel
type de mammifères placentaires il s'agit.
Pour savoir qui a raison
à l'heure actuelle.
Les deux approches doivent
encore s'affiner pour réaliser,
l'arbre le plus complet des mammifères.
Précision du rythme des mutations
génétiques d'un côté.
Et quête de fossiles dans les nouveaux
gisements de l'autre.
Pour éclairer les origines
des mammifères,
les paléontologues cherchent à comprendre,
comment ils se protégeaient
des dinosaures.
La capacité à allaiter leurs petits,
pourrait notamment
leur avoir été bénéfique.
Si nous voulons comprendre d'où
viennent les placentaires modernes,
nous devons nous tourner
vers leurs parents éloignés.
C'est le cas de ****,
un mammifère plus archaïque
que les placentaires,
dont le fossile a été découvert
en 1997 dans les gisements chinois.
Nous sommes relativement sûrs que c'est
un mammifère, car il avait de la fourrure,
ce qui est lié à toute une série
de fonctions reproductives.
Nous savons donc qu'il a dû
allaiter ses petits,
mais nous ignorons
s'il pondait des oeufs,
ou mettaient au monde
des petits vivants.
L'allaitement offre un avantage
certain lorsque la nourriture se fait rare,
car les petits sont nourris grâce aux
réserves corporelles de leur mère.
Il serait apparu sous la forme
d'une centaine de glandes,
répartis sur l'abdomen.
Comme chez les ornithorynques actuels.
Les jeunes devaient lécher un lait
épais le long des poils.
**** possède aussi un autre
point commun,
avec les Monotrèmes
comme l'ornithorynque.
Un aiguillon sur la patte arrière.
Un autre fossile de cet espèce a été
préservé avec un aiguillon osseux.
Il est très semblable
à celui que l'on voit,
directement sur ce spécimen.
Les Monotrèmes modernes utilisent
cet aiguillon pour se défendre,
mais nous ne savons pas si cet os
était réellement toxique ou pas.
Les crochets des serpents,
ou les dards des insectes
sont très répandus.
Mais cette technique de défense,
est assez rare
chez les mammifères actuels.
Situé sur les pattes
postérieures des mâles,
cet aiguillon devait
libérer un venin,
capable d'infliger de sérieuses
paralysies à leur adversaire.
Cette arme ne serait pas suffisamment
efficace selon les scientifiques,
car il faut du temps
au venin pour faire effet.
D'autres stratégies auraient
été privilégiées par l'évolution,
comme la fuite.
Et pour cela, quoi de mieux qu'une ouïe fine,
afin d'échapper aux confrontations.
En 2011, la découverte
de ce fossile de Liaoconodon,
vieux de 120 millions d'années,
indique enfin comment les os
de la mâchoire des reptiles,
ont migré pour former l'oreille
moyenne des mammifères modernes.
Ce spécimen de mammifère
est le plus complet,
jamais découvert au Liaoning occidental.
Tous les os sont intacts.
Ce qui en fait un très beau spécimen.
Les petits os de l'oreille notamment,
sont très bien préservés.
Les osselets fossiles
sont rarement intacts,
car ils sont minuscules.
Et plus important encore,
c'est une étape transitoire,
dans l'évolution de l'oreille
moyenne des mammifères.
Chez les mammifères archaïques,
la mâchoire inférieure
est reliée au crâne,
via un os allongé.
C'est celui-ci qui a évolué chez
Liaoconodon pour commencer à former,
les os de l'audition.
Marteau, enclume et étrier,
se sont ensuite détachés
chez les mammifères modernes,
pour former l'oreille interne.
De façon étonnante,
chaque embryon de mammifère,
humain inclus,
reproduit dans l'utérus,
cette étape évolutive durant
la formation des oreilles internes.
Ces outils de précision,
analysent ce qui se passe
autour de nous en permanence.
Si un animal peut percevoir
le danger avant les autres,
il pourra mieux fuir les prédateurs.
Lien avec notre passé reptilien,
le mystère des os de l'oreille
interne est ainsi éclairé,
grâce à ce fossile remarquable.
Autre armes des mammifères,
leurs dents.
Elles sont étudiées aux Etats-Unis, sur
le campus de l'Université de Washington.
C'est là que Gregory Wilson,
analyse avec des technologies de pointe,
celles des multituberculés,
des mammifères disparus
il y a 34 millions d'années.
Nos résultats sont vraiment enthousiasmants.
Nous avons découvert que ces mammifères
vivants auprès des dinosaures,
se sont diversifiés
20 millions d'années,
avant la disparition des dinosaures.
Nous observons que leurs dents,
qui possédaient quelques pointes,
leur permettant
de croquer des insectes,
ont ensuite développé
des pointes multiples.
Autant d'outils pour accéder
à une nouvelle ressource.
Les plantes à fleurs.
Cette capacité à exploiter
cette nouvelle ressource,
permet aux multituberculés
de se développer,
en nombre d'espèces différentes,
mais aussi en taille,
si bien qu'ils ont pu survivre,
à l'extinction massive
des dinosaures.
Cette étude publiée en 2012,
montre que les multituberculés
se sont diversifiés,
bien avant la disparition des dinosaures.
Passant d'un régime insectivore,
à une alimentation à base de fruits,
ou même d'Angiosperme,
Les plantes à fleurs apparuent
pendant le Crétacé.
Pour parvenir à cet étonnant résultat,
Grégory Wilson exploite les fossiles
récoltés depuis 100 ans,
dans le delta de Hell Creek,
au Montana.
Une collection de dents qu'il a
longtemps étudiées au microscope,
pour se familiariser avec les nombreuses
espèces de multituberculés.
Voici le plus grand des multituberculés.
De la taille d'un castor
ou d'une marmotte.
De nombreuses bosses
se trouvaient à l'intérieur.
Ces bosses servent à écraser
et broyer la nourriture.
On en trouve un autre exemple
dans ce petit tube.
Cet autre multituberculés possède aussi
des dents munies de multiples bosses.
C'est une plus petite version de
cet animal du temps des dinosaures.
Nous connaissons cette lignée
depuis très longtemps,
mais il était difficile de comprendre
ce que signifiait la forme de ses dents.
Nous avions tenté
de multiples approches,
mais aucune ne nous
a donné la précision.
que nous pouvons
atteindre aujourd'hui.
Cette révolution technologique,
c'est le CT-Scan,
un outil d'imagerie médicale,
utilisé aujourd'hui
par les paléontologues.
Les dents sont scannées aux rayons X,
à l'échelle millimétrique,
tel ce spécimen âgé
de 67 millions d'années.
Il est identifiable à sa longue incisive.
Mais ce qui intéresse le chercheur,
c'est la complexité de ses molaires.
À partir des données collectées,
un logiciel de cartographie reconstitue
très précisément la forme des dents.
Gregory Wilson découvre ainsi
que les carnivores,
ont une structure dentaire assez simple.
Avec 110 bosses par rangées de dents.
Alors que celle des multituberculés
est bien plus complexe,
avec jusqu'à 348 bosses.
Le spécimen que je viens d'afficher,
possède environ 250 petits
outils complexes,
à la surface de cette rangée de dents.
Ces outils servent à broyer
la matière végétale très finement,
pour une digestion efficace.
Ces animaux ont donc évolué vers
la consommation de plantes.
Cette nouvelle fonction
de broyage des dents,
aurait favorisé l'explosion
d'espèces herbivores.
Une niche écologique inexploitée
par les tout premiers mammifères.
Malgré ces multiples découvertes,
une question cruciale reste irrésolue,
à la fin des années 2000.
Quand la lignée des mammifères
est-elle apparue ?
Encore une fois, c'est du Liaoning
que vient la réponse à cette énigme.
Lorsqu'en 2011, des paysans chinois
trouvent dans leur champ,
le fossile d'un mammifère
nommé Juramaia sinensis,
pour mère jurassique de Chine.
Le paléontologue, Zhe-Xi Luo,
vient pour la première fois,
visiter cette zone étendue
sur plusieurs kilomètres.
Difficile de repérer les roches fossilifères
sous les foisonnantes plantations de maïs.
Mais il est guidé par un collègue local
spécialiste des dinosaures à plumes,
dont le plus ancien
spécimen Anchiornis,
a été exhumé dans
un gisement tout proche.
C'est une découverte fossile
tout à fait passionnante.
Car elle nous donne un nouveau repère,
pour la première apparition de la
lignée des placentaires sur Terre.
Tous les mammifères
placentaires modernes,
ayant des racines
profondes au Jurassique,
viennent vraiment d'ici.
Ces roches sont également mêlées
à des cendres volcaniques.
La géochronologie à dater ce site,
à environ 160 millions d'années.
Nous sommes donc sûrs que ces roches
remontent bien à la fin du Jurassique.
Le fossile de Juramaia est une pièce
majeure de l'évolution des mammifères.
C'est le plus ancien spécimen
du genre placentaire.
Identifié grâce à ses dents
composées de molaires,
de canines et d'incisives.
Comme le suggère l'analyse
génétique des mammifères,
leur origine serait plus ancienne,
que ne le laissaient présager
les fossiles connus jusque là.
Car Juramaia repousse la date
d'apparition des placentaires,
de 35 millions d'années
par rapport à Eomaia.
Et même si les paléontologues sont
toujours en quête de fossiles du Crétacé,
appartenant aux groupes actuels,
comme les rongeurs ou les carnivores,
cette découverte rapproche
généticiens et paléontologues.
Des études indépendantes obtenues
par les fossiles d'un côté,
et la génétique de l'autre,
nous confirme que nous
approchons de la bonne réponse.
Avec Juramaia,
dès 160 millions d'années.
les mammifères possèdent déjà
les traits qui feront leur succès.
Fourrure, dentition complexe,
et ouïe fine pour échapper
aux prédateurs,
ou bien repérer leurs proies.
L'adaptation aux régimes insectivores,
et la capacité à se déplacer
dans les arbres,
ont conféré des avantages évolutifs
certain à ce mammifère.
Il est déjà assez bien équipé
à la fin du Jurassique,
pour permettre à ses descendants
de prospérer,
après la disparition des dinosaures.
Certes, les ancêtres des mammifères
sont pour la plupart des lilliputiens,
à l'époque des dinosaures.
Mais bien plus variés et mieux
équipés qu'on l'a longtemps pensé.
Avec des atouts que l'on retrouvera
plus tard chez les primates.
La famille dont les humains sont issus.